Federal officials are considering a ban
on gas stoves over concerns about the
health effects of air pollutants the
very stoves and and cooktops found in
about 40 percent of American homes but
now the U.S consumer product safety
commission is considering Banning gas
stoves over concerns about harmful
pollutants they say research links them
to asthma respiratory illnesses the
association of Home Appliance
manufacturers says a banal gas stoves
would not address the overall issue they
say improving ventilation is a better
solution
foreign
report it's January 12 2023 we're live
streaming on Rumble and YouTube If you
have not subscribed to rumble.com Ruben
report go ahead and do that uh tap the
notification Bell and I'm told people I
just got breaking news on my magical
light box here right before we started
that yesterday
was our biggest day ever in views in
Channel History
just putting that out there biggest Day
Ever if you're watching today you're
watching history in real time that's
what's going on we got a big show for
you today we are doing a
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
questions are all over the place a
little personal a little political
social cultural all that good stuff but
I wanted to start with a a quick
combination of things you know yesterday
we really focused on the positive stuff
and there really is a lot of positive
stuff happening right now as I said the
Republicans are getting balls that's
pretty good having balls generally
thought of as a good thing whether
you're a dude or a chick having balls
now everybody wants them so that's good
obviously some of the school choice
stuff that's happening
fighting against the overreach of
government related to covet and
surveillance and and censorship and all
these things like it's happening
throughout the country right now and we
have to make uh specific markers when
those things happen so that we go oh
look we talk about these things and then
some people step up and good things
start happening today we're going to do
a quick recap on just some of the
general lunacy that's happening amidst
that because the craziness is just going
to continue so we're going to talk about
lesbians near water we're going to talk
about evil world leaders we're going to
talk about gas stoves and vaccines and a
whole bunch more uh let's get right to
it actually why not uh as you guys know
there there are these massive rain
storms happening all across California
right now and a video of Ellen DeGeneres
America's number one lesbian she is the
top lesbian I checked this morning there
are several powerful lesbians out there
obviously Corinne Jean-Pierre is up on
the top 10 lesbian list who do you got
who else is on the top 10 lesbian list
you got your Lori light but she's around
seven or eight depending on which list
you're looking at who else is a big
lesbo these days who
is Brittany Greiner a lesbo she seems
like a lesbian who else give me I want
two more lesbians give me a lesbian give
me a lesbian
um
Ellen's wife
come on one more big lesbian uh how
about is there an old lesbian we can
think of or who who Meredith Baxter
Bernie that's a real throwback you know
who she was she was the mother in uh not
a family ties with Michael J fox all
right so the point is lesbians are out
there we can all think what we want
about lesbians anyway Ellen's a lesbian
she was also a daytime talk show always
a comedian for many years she's out
there in California and there's all
these crazy Reigns and she put up this
selfie video in the midst of it right
behind her house and she's getting some
pushback on some of her thoughts take a
look
so
Montecito is under complete evacuation
the entire town this is beside your
anniversary
and
their homes their lives
in the five-year anniversary
thank everybody
yikes all right first before we get to
the content of that I just want to name
a couple other lesbians because the guys
were on the computer machines checking
lesbians while we were doing this we
know what you're doing over there
Melissa Etheridge huge lesbian and I
should have said something about her I'm
sorry that one didn't happen come to my
window remember that song that was what
she sang and Tracy Chapman who I think
also had a song about a window lesbians
are always looking out windows anyway
there's a lot of lesbians out there the
the line though that got Ellen on that
and first off before I just do the funny
stuff about this anyone that's losing
property or life or anything up there
it's obviously a humanitarian disaster
I'm not making fun of that to any degree
and even though this is happening in
California while many people were happy
when we had you know natural disasters
here in Florida I don't celebrate any of
that stuff the line that people are are
getting her on that uh is the at the end
there when she said Mother Nature is
angry at us as if we have something to
do when there are these storms and there
are these mudslides and all these things
I mean the irony of course is that
California for the last decade I moved
to California in 2013 and from the day I
was there we were always in the midst of
a drought they would not water the grass
people I think what's his name Tom
Selleck got in a lot of trouble because
he was watering his grass one day during
the drought so they when there's a
drought it's climate change when it
rains too much it's Climate Change
Mother Nature is angry at us as if we
have dominion over everything Mother
Nature you think she was a lesbo she
might have been a lesbian we do not know
a couple other lesbians the Indigo Girls
Martina Navratilova and Megan rappinow
tremendous lesbians out there anyway
Ellen's getting a lot of pushback on
this thing I think just the reason I
want to do it is this this concept that
we that everything revolves around us
the humans you know George Carlin did a
funny thing about you know the line was
on climate change it was like the Earth
is going to be fine it's the humans that
are going to have problems it's
something like that that every that they
all think we have a drought it's our
fault it Reigns too much it's our fault
this it's our fault it's all for it and
why do they always talk about this kind
of stuff or or why are they always
saying these crazy things that have
nothing to do with reality right if they
only recycled more plastic bags then it
wouldn't rain or it would rain or
whatever it might be the reason they do
is because they are really programmed by
a machine to make it seem that uh that
they are the problem that somehow we
humans are the problem and if only there
was this group of people that were
somehow better than us more enlightened
than us also richer than us and if they
could just meet say once a year in a
secret place and talk about how we
should live our lives well then things
would be much better and that is quite
literally happening so here is video of
the world economic forum's Klaus Schwab
Klaus Schwab who is right at a Central
Casting as an 80s Schwarzenegger or Mel
Gibson movie villain uh here he is
talking about all the rich people who
are about to get together in Davos and
talk about how you should live your life
it is so exciting so that's the
beginning of the year we can meet again
in person
only personal interaction creates a
necessary level of trust which we need
so much in our fragmented and fractured
world
to bring people together
for an informal dialogue in a remote
Swiss Village such as Davos can be or
should be a good recipe to restore Trust
Central Casting 101 with this guy if you
were coming up with a bad guy to lead
the Elites in a movie that the action
hero was gonna have to bust in and take
care of business at the end it would be
Klaus Schwab so you see they make us
think that the weather is coming to kill
all of us they make us think that kovid
is coming to kill all of us
etc
etc and somehow they will meet in a
remote I like how he said it has to be
in a remote Village I mean we can't just
do this you know just where people are
hanging out they have to be in a remote
village where they will have an informal
dialogue yes it'll be very informal over
foie gras and champagne as they discuss
the policies that they will institute in
our governments as if they have any
control over our governments now they do
they should not but they do uh the guy's
evil the guy is absolutely evil but what
are the solutions that globalists come
up with do they come up the solutions
that free more people that help you
figure out you know or help create the
conditions so that you can live your
life as you see fit is that what they're
interested in doing are they interested
in say spreading capitalism which of
course is the idea that we can all
together rise together because of
competition and human Ingenuity and
individual thought and all of that stuff
is is that what they're pushing on us or
is it always about taking something away
whether that's your ability to go
outside or your right to Medical privacy
or perhaps even to cook on a simple gas
stove gas stoves could soon get 86 from
kitchens across the country going
forward the U.S consumer product safety
commissioner is considering a ban on the
appliances for new builds it says those
appliances can be a source of indoor
pollution
sometimes linked to Childhood asthma but
also the gas no gas lines and new
construction is that about fossil fuels
or is it about
sorry I'm getting in trouble no well no
that's that's a short answer it's about
climate change because methane is 80
times more powerful than CO2 when it
comes to heating up the planet so big
time but but in small spaces it's
personal health okay it is an incredible
moment that happened there on CNN you
know I've often talked to you guys about
how so I have a thing in my ear when I
do this show it's not because anyone's
talking to me or telling me what to do
it's so that when we play those videos
so that we don't get feedback I can
actually hear the video so as you're
watching them live I can hear them
through here now she the host of CNN
over there she's getting information as
she's talking right they're telling her
what to say or they're telling her not
what to say she was getting in trouble
what what also the fact that CNN is now
doing stories on the problems with gas
stoves it's funny they weren't doing it
last week but suddenly the Democrats and
the Machine want to go after your gas
stove so now CNN starts telling you
about all the problems with gas stoves I
want to be very clear you [ __ ]
are sorry Kristen now we're getting
demonetized I did it no lunch for
anybody uh you're you're never coming
from my gas stove when we moved here to
Florida the street that I live on does
not have uh natural gas to each of the
houses so we had an electric stove here
David is a great chef I talked about
this yesterday I've gotten actually
pretty good myself I really enjoy
cooking now and cooking on an electric
stove is not fun it is mechanical and
Technical there's no feel for it that's
why no Chef go to any restaurant any
great restaurant go to any mediocre
restaurant basically go to any
restaurant on Earth and they're cooking
with fire you know people have been
cooking for fire for a long time the
cavemen it was a long time ago they were
cooking with fire fire good okay uh you
are not coming the first thing we did
was uh we removed that electric thing we
tried to figure out if there was a way
to do something like crazy crazy thing
to get gas to the house couldn't do that
but we got propane buried a tank outside
and now we have fire and that's what
we're cooking with and you ain't coming
for it I'll have more on that in just a
second but what they do is everything
they want you to be afraid of everything
so this video uh this is from about a
year and a half ago this is making the
rounds again and uh
by golly I think this might be some very
influential people sharing
misinformation this is well just take a
look and remember this from about a year
and a half ago I think you'll recognize
these fellas our fellow Americans right
now the covid-19 vaccines are available
to millions of Americans and soon they
will be available to everyone the
science is clear these vaccines will
protect you and those you love from this
dangerous and deadly disease they could
save your life so we urge you to get
vaccinated when it's available to you
that's the first step to ending the
pandemic and moving our country forward
it's up to you
misinformation and lies the science is
clear it'll protect you and your loved
ones no it isn't none of them got in
trouble for any of that they're also
social distancing six feet apart as if
they didn't shake hands and hug each
other right before that it's all just
nonsense our world leaders and whether
it's the whether it's the world leader
leader in quotes Klaus Schwab or the
former presidents or the machine that
talks in people's ears while they're
supposedly giving the news I'm getting
in trouble what a bizarre thing to say
on the news I'm getting in trouble
shouldn't someone be asking who who said
that something to her why is she getting
in trouble but that they lie about
everything they could have had Joe Biden
up there too remember you uh if you get
the vaccine you will got not get nor
transmit covid but this is not just an
American thing obviously this is all
over the world cue Justin Trudeau just a
day or two ago he's very worried about
global authoritarian leaders because
obviously irony is dead
the world today is facing a lot of
uncertainty with the rise in
authoritarian leaders causing Global
instability and the High Cost of Living
putting stress on families at home
he is just such a piece of work we
didn't have to dig too deep for this one
here's just one of the many moments of
Justin Trudeau being evil over the last
year or so
we are not intimidated
by those who hurl insults and abuse at
small business workers
and steal food
from the homeless
we won't give in
to those who fly racist Flags
we won't cave
to those who engage in vandalism
I had to write some of that down so
first off he's talking about the
truckers the truckers were insulting
small business owners the truckers were
small business owners you you lizard man
you were the one that were locking these
people out of their jobs right making
sure that their kids couldn't go to
school they were the home the truckers
were stealing food from homeless people
like what in the world does that mean
generally homeless people don't have a
lot of food if you were going to steal
food from somebody you'd go to Justin
Trudeau's house because no doubt he's
got a whole freaking uh refrigerator
full of poutine
you know what poutine is it's like a
it's like a gravy that they put on their
french fries instead of ketchup it's
wild uh I don't like that guy I don't
like that guy uh but what do we do and
then we'll get to the Q a in just a sec
what do we do about all this stuff uh
well there are answers and the answer is
not only are make sure that we can still
communicate with each other honestly and
and do this to the best of our ability
which of course is why I'm doubling down
on everything I'm doing with Rumble and
locals because even though yesterday was
our biggest day ever on YouTube you
don't know when they could pull the plug
right
um so we have to do that but we have to
communicate with our family and our
neighbors and share good information and
show people that two years ago we're
demanding everyone get facts that the
vaxes aren't working you know I'm gonna
I'll throw a little conspiracy theory
out that I've been thinking about for
the last week and someone you guys at
home uh comment on this please and I'll
check in the locals Community especially
um I have a theory now that people who
are waxed are getting more sick in
general than non-vaxed people I
mentioned to you guys how
couple weeks ago I was at a family event
I'm not vaxxed everyone else there was
vaxxed literally everybody aunts uncle's
cousin's sister people younger than me
older than me everyone got coveted I was
the only one not sick right not with
symptoms of covet I don't think I am
Superman right I like to drink a little
water in the morning I'm doing the best
I can try to get out do a little cardio
you know I'm doing okay but I don't even
mean with covid I think that in general
it seems to me that a lot of people who
got vaxed have been more sick in general
people are getting more sick I don't
know is that a completely crazy
conspiracy theory I'm just putting it
there and and we can revisit that in the
future but one of the guys who is called
a crazy conspiracy theorist for a long
time is the guy who invented and has
more patents on the MRNA vaccine than
anyone else Dr Robert Malone and of
course you guys remember Dr Robert
Malone from the uh the interview that he
did with Joe Rogan where he talked about
what is going on here and he talked
about Mass formation psychosis and a
whole bunch more he wrote a tweet that I
thought was pretty interesting on what a
solution to the current problem is he
said we have to build alternate
alternate systems we probably can't
completely stop them or globalization
but we can choose not to buy their food
take their drugs or weird vaccines and
we can be in charge of our own health we
can be independent people and
communities outside of their hellscape
and that is the guy ladles and jelly
spoons who basically invented mRNA
technology and he is now telling you you
gotta watch out for this and you got to
watch out for what all this means and
why do they have to meet in a secret
remote Village in Davos and keep you
scared of everything and why does no one
get fired why does no one no one at the
CDC has been fired or the NIH has been
fired why didn't anyone sit George W
bush down and smack him across the face
and say you lied in in that video you
also killed a couple million people
unnecessarily in Iraq but we'll let that
one slide but this seems like a bit much
I think you know why so it's rhetorical
but anyway let's do some Community
questions Snow Baby Says have you
decided to go to uh oh I see have you
decided on your go-to back in my day
story for the boys can you share it with
us my dad's favorite story especially
when he was disappointed with us was I
had a job when I was eight years old
shoveling [ __ ] on the neighbor's farm so
what will be mine like you know I grew
up with look at you guys you have
everything I'm a big star I give you
everything and this is how you treat me
um I gotta have to think like what was
the uh you know I I had to walk to
school we had to walk to school in my
day we did not have buses I lived about
a block away it was about it was about a
20-foot walk I lived right there but I
had to walk to school these kids are
going to probably get driven to school
little bastards uh okay
I did have my lean years too I always
tell you guys about when I was doing
stand up and like you know you make no
money or you get a couple bucks or if
anything they give you a beer or
whatever and I was doing all sorts of
odd jobs I was bartending and waiting
tables and working for PR companies and
handing out [ __ ] on the streets and all
this stuff and I had no money nothing I
was I remember going through my buddy's
uh little change jar just to buy a cup
of coffee once but I had a friend who
was in food service and he used to bring
me industrial sized packets of tuna they
come in these big well you'd get them in
cans or you get the really big ones in
giant try to picture like a giant I'm
talking like 10 pounds of tuna in like a
vacuum sealed thing and I would just be
eating tuna out of that thing day after
day mercury poisoning it's a miracle I'm
here Alan says greetings from Melbourne
Australia the lockdown capital of the
world Rhonda santis for president and
Byron Donalds for Florida Governor or
vice versa a win for the USA in Florida
what do you think
I'm down brother I am I am completely
down with that look the DeSantis thing I
don't know if it's happening but there's
every reason it should happen Byron
Donald's in my interview with him in DC
a couple weeks ago he implied that if
the governor was to move on to something
bigger that he would be interested in
the governorship here in Florida he
obviously has a bright future and the
reason we did the show the way we did
yesterday was to show you that he's
leveling up at the moment and he's a
good he's a good decent man who of
course they will tell you is the
blackface of white supremacy and all
that stuff real quick on Melbourne
Australia that was one of my favorite
stops on the tour well the whole
Australia thing that we did with Jordan
we did about two weeks in Australia it
was absolutely wonderful uh you know
Sydney and Melbourne
and Perth I mean we went all over the
country and it's such a freaking massive
country we went to the capital is uh
what's the uh Canberra which is right in
the middle of nowhere
um we I just the people of Australia
were amazing it was such like there was
like a feeling of like they're like
Americans but like a little more like
just like a little less politically
correct actually than Americans like a
little more out there so that's why it's
so disappointing to me what happened in
Australia so I I hope things turn around
over there I really do uh Larry says
what's your personal belief on what
happens when we die wow we're going deep
today
um
how about something like this I don't
think this is it I don't think this is
it I think it's something a little bit
like if you ever saw the movie Defending
Your Life the great Albert Brooks movie
with Meryl Streep where uh he's a he's
like a record executive or something and
he gets in a car accident and the movie
is basically about his trial the trial
of his life to see if he moves forward
or if he goes back to Earth to do it all
over again and I think it's something
like that that you are here to kind of
figure out some stuff maybe do it a
little better than you did it last time
like I know there's some like
reincarnation thing with that I I don't
think this is it I don't think this is
it and I don't think that you know right
after this if you live like the greatest
life ever and do it all right that
there's some like just magical
Shangri-La or that if you're really bad
here that you're going to spend an
eternity in hell I think it's something
about trying like every time you're here
you have like a little more of an
opportunity to do it a little bit better
better and I think maybe we all kind of
maybe know that too but to really like
stare that down and have that moment of
like whoa I've got another chance to do
it better am I going to actually do it
that's that's pretty daunting something
like that uh Kevin says uh does David
Janet have to ask you to quit walking
around the house saying Luke I am your
father there is a lot of Luke I am your
father in this house we've discussed
when we're gonna show them Star Wars for
the first time they're not fully
speaking English yet although Justin is
beginning to teethe seemingly as of last
night so there's some new screeching in
the house uh but yes there will be
although I did say when uh when I told
you guys that we named Luke I didn't
want this to be about Star Wars so
we are he's really named after Uncle
Lucas who was played by Leslie Nielsen
in the finale of The Golden Girls
married uh Dorothy ended up moving to
Hollingsworth Manor in Georgia but you
guys know that Martin says uh wouldn't
it have been easier
for Rachel Levine to change her name
from dick to [ __ ]
I wish I would have thought of that
yes [ __ ] Levine would make more
sense although I'd ah here we go I gotta
I gotta have you guys Google this does
Rachel Levine have a wang you want to
Google this Phoenix
man to go into your guys search history
after working for me
like did Rachel Levine do that so Rachel
Levine who we know is the Deputy
assistant Health secretary whatever who
wants all these kids to have their nuts
chopped off and everything she was Dick
or he was Dick living in his whole life
wait you gave me a thumbs down meaning
he wow so dick Levine is [ __ ] Levine
he did you know so that's the one to me
if you're going to go ahead and as a you
know you're going to be a 40 something
year old and be like I've had it with
this penis and then chop that thing off
that's what Caitlyn Jenner did too then
I'm going to give you a certain amount
of credit but if you're going to be like
the other one that Dylan Mulvaney who
shows up at the White House just dressed
like a chick with a wang and then tell
everyone that you're a girl it's like
you chop that thing off and then we'll
talk hope says what's your best piece of
business advice to other business owners
um it ain't gonna be easy
it ain't going to be easy but just keep
going and don't take no for an answer
you just keep going remember that clip
we showed you what was that two or three
days ago that Donald Trump clip about
never give up and that you might run
into a concrete wall wall but you got to
be flexible you got to work know how to
do things like I can tell you having
created created this show which then we
had to create a production company
around it which these guys all work for
the production company then we created
locals which was the startup that I had
to raise funds for and we had to build a
product and we didn't even we didn't
know what the hell we were doing
honestly I was just like can we do
something and then and then it starts
moving it starts happening and you've
got to spend a lot of time like not
thinking about the the money at the end
of the day like when we did when we did
locals well first off there's no money
like when you have a startup there's no
money for it no one gives you money to
be like I would like to take a salary
while I'm doing the startup no they want
you to freaking starve and see how bad
you want it and I didn't fully realize
that so I was I was also putting some
money into locals and I was working I
mean at the height of uh before we
merged with Rumble I would say probably
60 or 70 percent of my day believe it or
not was doing local stuff whether it was
talking to the programmers about the
functions we wanted or whether it was
raising funds or going to dinners to
meet the investors or whatever and you
and I didn't know if it was going to
work I didn't know if we were going to
ever merge with the company or be
acquired and then Rumble ended up going
public and it did all work but there
were definitely times in that where I
was like I don't know what I'm doing
like I'm putting all this money and
effort into this thing I'm trying to
fight big Tech like is this the craziest
Adventure ever but if you believe that
you're building something good whether
that's a tech company or whether you're
selling you know chapstick or whatever
it's like you just keep going and going
and going and you you you will find a
way I I really believe that you will
find a way if you're building something
good and you're doing it right and
you're working with good people and all
that you will find a way uh Joe says are
there any states in the U.S that you
haven't visited but would like to yes
Alaska I've never been to Alaska I would
love to go to Alaska
more of a warm weather guy generally
speaking which is why I loved Cali for a
certain set of reasons and then hated it
at the end but it wasn't because of the
weather and I love Florida and I love
the humidity here and the Heat and all
that stuff but I would love to go to
Alaska I'd love to do a cruise up in
Alaska and go see the salmon and the
Bears and all that stuff if anyone is
watching in Alaska and you've got some
good ideas or a place for me to stay or
something like that I think that would
be uh that would be pretty awesome as
far as the continental United States
I think I've pretty much at least driven
through everywhere you know we when we
moved from New York to Cali in 2013 we
did the drive through stopped in a lot
of states did a lot a bunch of different
stuff I'm trying to think if there's any
state
that I absolutely have not been to
you know I don't know that I've been to
North Dakota
I've been to South Dakota
don't think I've been to North Dakota
I guess I'll maybe stop on the way to
Alaska we'll see Joe says are there oh
no we got that one already uh Unida says
uh Phoenix you gotta scroll with me here
any updates on the that's all I got
oh sorry all right the the scroller's
not working over here I gotta look down
there any updates on the member intro
messaging feature oh that's on locals
one of the things that we're going to
try to build out and that we've been
working on is I want members on locals
to be able to message each other right
now you can you can message me obviously
people are publicly responding to each
other yes we're working on messenger
we're working on the bulk thing you know
I know a ton of you are asking about
that you know if you subscribe to me and
you subscribe to vivofry and Barnes and
you subscribe to Scott Adams or Tulsi
gabbard or whoever it might be
eventually if you're throwing in five or
seven dollars a month to everybody it
does start adding up I get that and our
goal here especially my goal here is not
that that my local community is purely a
money maker for what we're doing like I
love that we're obviously making some
money on it I am a capitalist I believe
that if you create something of value
you should get value back for it but I
really was trying to just create like an
actual Community online because that was
the promise of social media and the
internet way back when
um so we do want to build out some other
features like what I really want locals
to become is I want everybody to have
their own locals Community which will be
which would sort of hearken back to the
way Myspace or Facebook was intended to
be where you have this little home for
yourself where you can post your videos
and you can post your whatever your
stuff might be your your videos your
pictures whatever it is you can have
your connections friends family whoever
that is we're not going to own any of
that stuff we're kind of just renting
you the space right so you probably have
to pay a couple bucks to get in and then
you connect with who you want to connect
with that that really is the ultimate
goal and then have have a uh encrypted
messenger and a whole bunch more trust
me guys it takes a while to build stuff
out we also have some of the locals team
working on some of the rumble features
right now and as some of you might have
seen uh Rumble has a new UI which is out
right now which is much sleeker and
we're working on a whole bunch more
related to that we also now just in the
last week or so uh some of you that are
watching on locals right now we can
embed the rumble link into logo those
right now and you can watch the show
right in there which that's new so trust
me we're building out these things like
these guys are working hard and on top
of everything else
most of our programmers on the local
side were in Ukraine so when the war
broke out we helped some of them move to
some other places some of them were just
in the United States for a little bit
we're working on visas and a whole bunch
of other things so like there's a lot of
stuff here but we're working hard I
should say they're working hard mostly
you know I'm kind of guiding a little
bit from the way I can but there are
guys that are you know spending all day
on this stuff uh Lewin says have you
seen Jordan Peterson's Exodus series
it's freaking phenomenal yes I have I've
seen most of it it is absolutely
wonderful I actually sent Jordan an
email a day or two ago I said he's doing
the best work he's ever done you know we
play a lot of Jordan Clips on this show
obviously because I think so so much of
what he's talking about at a at a
psychological and cultural level is
related directly to our politics right
that and it sort of connects to what I
was talking about about the afterlife
before like like your life here and now
and what is your purpose what is the
point of being here and it is to to slay
that dragon and to go to that star and
all of those things but the biblical
stuff has been absolutely phenomenal
they're taping a whole bunch more right
now I think this week in Florida so I'm
going to see Jordan a couple times over
the next week or so and it's just great
to have him back and firing at all
cylinders and and doing good stuff and
as I mentioned I think maybe two weeks
ago or so you know I think what Jordan
did you know when he had those series of
debates about belief with Sam Harris I
think Jordan in many ways uh it's not
that you ever put an end to that debate
but in the the internet realm that we
all live in it's like he really won
those debates that that belief and
meaning
are deeply tied together and without
that without that uh Society starts
getting all screwy I know I had a couple
uh people in The Atheist Community kind
of angry at me when I said that a few
weeks ago I don't mean that every of
course there are great atheists
obviously obviously uh my buddy Pete
pagosian's gonna be on we're going to do
it live in Miami in in two or three
weeks and we're going to talk all about
that and he wrote a book a manual to
create atheists a manual for creating
atheists so I don't mean that I mean
that that ultimately as these systems
work if you just try to take out systems
that roughly work you better be ready to
replace it with a better system and lack
of belief is not a system so there you
go uh Rich says Dave I live in North
Port Florida I lived in Northport
Florida for 10 years we love visiting
Sanibel how are the loved ones doing
down there and did The Island Cow
survive so The Island Cow is a great
little diner right on Periwinkle which
is the there's really only one main road
in Sanibel and it was about halfway
right smack dab in the middle of the
island believe it or not if you did not
hear this I guess you did not uh Island
Cow burned down uh about a month or two
before the hurricane uh there was a I
think a grease fire in the kitchen and
it burned down uh so when I went to
Sanibel a couple weeks ago I went with
my dad to to check out their condo and
we had to take pictures for insurance
and we went around the island and I have
a couple friends that are on the island
now and it's it's slowly coming back to
life actually as of January 2nd the
island is now open to public traffic so
it was you know they rebuilt the
causeway unbelievably fast it was it was
absolutely incredible and one of the
reasons I'm so proud to be a Floridian
like they just cut the red tape and they
rebuilt this massive roadway that
connects Sanibel and Captiva to the
mainland you couldn't even tell where
the new parts were I mean it was really
really incredible uh but we went to my
parents place check that out you know
there's still garbage on the streets but
they've cleaned up an awful lot there is
electricity there's running water there
were a couple of restaurants
that were open
um I made sure to take care of everybody
that waited on us like these people are
their lives have been just absolutely
upended
um but it's getting better there it's
getting better there we also drove
around Fort Myers and you know Sanibel
as a as a Barrier Island you know it's
it's people that are mostly middle class
there's definitely some lower middle
class there but it's middle class and
upper class upper middle class let's say
there it's not like Ultra exclusive like
West Palm Beach kind of thing but it's
it's you got to have a little scratch to
live on an island like that we drove
through Fort Myers where you know
there's a lot of trailer park
communities a lot of like you know very
very small two-bedroom one-bathroom
houses that were absolutely demolished
so there is a lot of work that has to be
done but it's not just seeing the when
you see these buildings that are
absolutely destroyed which obviously is
is upsetting and you think that you know
that was somebody's home or whatever it
might be but when you see the amount of
nature that was destroyed because
Southwest Florida is so filled with with
beautiful nature and animals and birds
and all this stuff and you see these
trees that have probably been there for
200 years that are that are basically
you know L-shaped and and crushed and
but stuff's you know
Jeff Goldblum Jurassic Park life finds a
way and stuff starts turning green again
and they'll rebuild some of the the
coast you know the the uh all the
barrier areas and like good stuff will
happen so uh I hope to get down there
again over the next couple weeks my
dad's going to come back down we're
going to see what we can do to help and
eventually we will do that fundraiser
there uh we just didn't feel it was
appropriate while there was just such
chaos there but we will absolutely do it
I've already talked to Byron Donald's
about it as I've mentioned he's the the
congressman over there in Southwest
Florida and uh there's work to be done
but they will do it here in the Free
State of Florida uh what Dave says when
will Davina make another appearance on
The View it's been too long do we have a
little b-roll of Davina there she is
great woman
we were talking about lesbians earlier
she would she could have been a lesbian
maybe sort of uh that was Davina that
was one of my many characters I did take
an acting class for about three weeks in
probably 2004. I've mentioned one of the
people in my acting class was my my
friend who I was doing stand up with
Melissa Roush who is she was a
Bernadette on The Big Bang Theory and I
think her new show is coming out this
week she's they're doing a reboot of
Night Court do you hear about this on
NBC a reboot of Night Court she plays
Harry's the the judge Harry she plays
his uh his daughter
anyway obviously I'm an incredible actor
one more time with the video there look
at this woman
uh she was very upset with Whoopi and
joy right there when will she make her
return
do we know where that wig is definitely
you're in charge of the Reuben report
wigs where's the wig
all right we're gonna find that wig
she'll be back baby uh Elizabeth says
how did you know you wanted to marry
David
um well I've talked about this a little
bit before you know I I'm 46. I grew up
in a time that their gay marriage was
not a thing
I just sort of thought I could live my
life like kind of on the DL or maybe
marry a woman or something something and
then over time as as like gay and I hate
that's why I never I don't like all the
LGBT community or any of that stuff like
I have nothing to do with any of those
people but then sort of gay became
normal right like you could be an adult
and be gay and nobody really cared and
if you were a decent person that would
be good enough and that's really all
anyone should expect or ask for as that
became normal and I became more okay
with myself then I met David he's a
little younger than me and he grew up in
a time where it was it was already okay
so when we were hanging out and you know
going to dinners and whatever and he'd
be talking about that he wants to get
married one day he wants to have kids
one day and I was like that's nuts like
I never thought about that and I was
also so deep in my career a stand-up and
starting to do podcasting all these
things I was giving everything I had to
that you know and I think that that's uh
I think that's what happens in a lot of
ways you know what I mean like if you're
if you're kind of screwed up on whatever
your personal stuff is you can you can
basically sublimate a lot of that into a
very successful career in a lot of ways
because you can put all of that there as
opposed to having more holistic approach
to your personal life and your
professional life and all that kind of
stuff
um but he was he was always like yeah of
course I'm going to get married and I'm
going to have kids and live in the
suburbs and blah blah blah and I really
thought it was nuts but then over time
we were together for years we've been
together for 14 years now we've we've
got married in
2015 so we've been married for eight
years basically
um and now I see like we put those
pieces together I think at one point to
directly answer your question I I don't
remember exactly where I was but I
remember thinking like it's not going to
get better than this like if if I screw
this one up and I had screwed up some
other relationships in the past like if
I screwed this one up like it's fully on
me and I think that kind of was the
moment like you know and I think most
people get that like you're with
somebody I don't care if it's a dude or
a chick or a donkey whatever now they're
gonna go ahead no no donkeys don't do it
with donkeys that's the message today
but whether you're a dude with a dude or
a dude with a chick or a chick with a
dude or a chick with a chick
and you're standing by a river
complaining about climate change
whatever it is
um at some point you look somebody in
the eyes and it's like
all right like I if I screw this up this
one's fully on me because this is a
great person and that's really how it
happened uh Gracie says I think it would
be really nice to have a field trip to
some house debate with the locals
Community oh I love this idea uh because
I'm totally in I can't get to Florida
for the community meet and greet it
would be a fun day to watch the house
and have lunch not to mention it's safer
to go to DC in numbers with all the tent
cities which I swear get bigger time uh
get bigger every time I drive by there
that's a great idea so I mentioned on
the show yesterday that McCarthy is has
announced that as Congress gets back to
session they are going to open up the
house again they are going to let people
in those upper Rafters up there to watch
the debates to be there I absolutely
love this idea we will definitely do
this next time we're in DC when we set
up a whole bunch of interviews we'll
spend a couple days and I would love to
get uh you know we'll do some special
stuff for the locals Community but like
just get people there and we can all go
together and we'll do some some big
lunch or dinner or something I think
that would be absolutely fantastic we
could maybe do a big talk I always say
how the
the monument that I like the most is
sort of the least thought of Monument
there's the Jefferson Memorial which is
really off the beaten path because if
you're at the mall there you know it's a
sort of straight shot you got the
capital right there and then the
Washington Monument and you have the
Vietnam War Memorial right there and uh
and Lincoln Memorial they're all kind of
right connected but the Jefferson
Memorial is off a little bit and it's
really this this awesome uh
extraordinarily massive uh Stone
building where they have these great
writings of Jefferson on the wall it's
it's really uh it's just great I think
I'm gonna sneeze
well I think I got it I got a little
allergies last couple days that's uh
that's new for me but I'm a new
Floridian here uh Tony says now that
preparations are being made to get Kim K
out of California and into Florida to be
clear once again that's not Kim
Kardashian we have a locals Community
member named Kim K who we're helping
move from Cali to Florida are we
starting up a new collection how can we
community members donate to help to get
another person out so first off I'll
tell you I had a zoom call with Kim K
two days ago and Kim if you're watching
right now Kim lives in California she's
wanted to get out for a long time she
she liked being there for a while very
similar story to me actually kovid kind
of made her go crazy there she runs by
herself an animal shelter uh she's got I
think six dogs at the moment I bet I met
a bunch of dogs and I think there's some
cats there too and she's trying to
figure out how to get out she was
actually in La at first now she's a
little bit
more of the suburbs so we had a we had a
great chat she has a few things she has
to figure out in terms of how she want
where she wants to be and everything
else and then we'll figure out how
specifically I can help her whether
that's getting in a truck myself and
driving the dogs cross country which
actually sounds like a lot of fun or
completely psychotic or or how we're
going to help financially and everything
so we'll have more on that uh as far as
like a sounds like you want to do like a
GoFundMe or something to help some other
people I think there's something there's
something interesting there let me let
me think about that a little bit but
yeah we haven't been doing the jar since
then I want to see how much help she
actually needs and then and then we'll
go from there and our final question of
the day uh Amy Says in your opinion who
has worse drivers LA or Miami
this one is tough
this one is tough
Daphne's saying Miami what do you I want
to get all your opinions before I get
you think Miami for sure what do you
think crazier drivers in Miami Miami the
thing about Miami drivers is first off
I've said this before we have so many
different cultures here people from so
many different parts of the world Miami
is the most International City I think
in the United States that all the people
that come here they bring their own
traditions and foods and ways of
speaking and languages and all those
things but they also bring their own
driving traditions and I have to say
that in a lot of the Latin countries and
we've got a lot of Venezuelans and
Cubans these guys are driving with one
hand looking at the phone speaking in
Spanish they're I mean they're you know
like halfway through the light making a
left they don't care they're this that
you know
then of course you have to deal with the
iguanas falling out of the sky when it's
a little chillier here
um it's a yeah it's probably a little
crazier here uh the thing is LA
you'd get on that foreign was it the 405
right the hell you get on the 405 and
people are out to kill you here it
doesn't seem like people are trying to
kill you they're just like living their
own life listening to their music really
loud going to party that's more of the
Miami attitude La they want to kill you
and everyone you know and themselves
laughs
I don't miss L.A at all uh guys I hope
you enjoyed the Community Q a if you
want to take part next time join us at
reubenreport.locals.com part two of my
interview with Tulsi gabbard is up
across platforms full things up already
at locals uh obviously ad free uh we
leave you with our cold clothes I think
you'll recognize this guy I apologize in
advance and are we doing a post game we
do a post game show on Thursdays yeah
I'll be back in as I always say 42
seconds
we know that the president has made
probably over a thousand false
statements about the Russia issues
[Music]